yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
your data is your business protect it
at expressvpn.com yang
i have friends in silicon valley who
could not watch silicon valley or show
on hbo because they said it just
hit too close to hope they were like
it's too real
for me it was a real wake-up call
because i think it was season two or
three
we would sort of do these trips right we
would go to silicon valley and we would
show the episode and we'd sort of like
tour companies and get to see what they
were working on and they were very
excited to have us because
because you know we're we're doing a
show about
about about what they do i was stunned
at what little thought was going into
the moral and ethical ramifications of
the technology that they were working on
i remember i won't name the company but
they were showing us this new product
that's now on the market that
many people have and they were like you
do this can do this i could do this
and so we brought up a privacy concern
they were shocked that they were asked
this question
they didn't even have like a fake
corporate answer ready to go
they were stunned and a little upset and
disappointed
that we would even think of that
[Music]
[Applause]
so we just got breaking news andrew
literally right this second
you want to break it yeah the feds are
uh bringing a suit against
the dr robert hadden that assaulted
evelyn
and dozens maybe hundreds of other women
uh it looks like he's going to be
sent to jail uh and
they're picking up where the d.a of
manhattan somehow declined
to prosecute and so the doctor has been
sitting in a house in new jersey
essentially taking early retirement and
i am so
thrilled that justice is being done
uh though it's very late in coming
not just for all the women that suffered
at the hands of of dr hadden but also
in my mind he's a danger still you know
i mean
the the guy is uh like a
pathological sex offender just free
walking around in
new jersey uh i don't even think he had
to
put his name on any registry or record
so you know like
and so the fact that he's being
sent to prison uh it's
it's a massive relief and it's also
a massive source of pride because i feel
like he'd still be free if not for
evelyn's courage coming forward so thank
you to everyone who supported evelyn
and thrilled that justice is being done
better late than than ever
so i was with evelyn when she did her
cnn interview
um a couple things there's there's
nothing
you can do to take back the horror this
man has caused
in so many people's lives um in evelyn's
and
and many other women but um hopefully
this is some sort of
um this feels like justice and feels
great um
it's one of the reasons we love cnn dana
bash and bridget nolan who we worked
with on the piece and their whole team
were just
they were world class they were just um
sensitive they were real but they were
um they were honest they were fair
um and it's obviously a tough topic um
so i'm forever grateful i think we all
are and i'll say this
um our campaign did a lot of things um
and a lot of good things
um but if the only reason we ran was to
put that guy behind bars somehow that
still feels
worth it you know um yeah
this is a this is a pure good we
accomplish people so thank you
and uh and thank you for all the support
for all yeah and thank you for support
for
um evelyn and our family
uh she really appreciates it and now
there are a lot of uh women right now
who
who are also feeling like
their voices were heard and that they
had some measure of
uh justice for this doctor that
assaulted so many of them
yeah it's um
you know world right now where things
are pretty dark there's not much
to look forward to all the time this is
this is good news this feels [ __ ]
good
you know it feels really good so uh
rotten jail dr haddock what's his name i
don't even bother learning that guy's
name
dr hadden yeah i wanted to share with
all of you and for all of you that were
involved um with
sharing or supporting evelyn or the love
thank you thank you
thank you um justice was served all
right guys on today's episode we've got
the one and only
camille nanjani star of silicon valley
star of the big sick writer of big sick
and also just got ripped for his new
marvel movie pretty cool but before that
andrew and i talk about wwe we talk
about wildfires we talk about ransomware
and we even make some
hot nfl predictions as a season just
opened so
tune in camille nanjiani
and andrew yang here on yang speaks
welcome back to yank speaks andrew how
are you living man
coveted fine 20 20 good um you know the
there's always a qualifier but i can't i
certainly can't complain
oh man um so the pressing issue this
week man
you you went off relatively unprompted
although i've heard you go off on this
um in private and a couple times in the
campaign show you just went on a twitter
rampage on
um on labor day against vince mcmahon
who is the founder and i guess ceo still
of the world
world wrestling entertainment wwe ss
stands for cloud connecticut business
you might know it well
yeah so it wasn't entirely unprompted uh
they came out with a policy that was
restricting
pro wrestlers uh from using cameo
under their name and likeness which uh
struck me as absolutely ridiculous uh
and so the so the first thing i said was
wow this is strange given that they're
independent contractors it's like on
what universe can you restrict
independent contractors from
just going on and uh leaving video
messages
of themselves uh but then
uh i thought like uh
about what it really meant and you're
right that
i've been thinking about this for a
while uh and i came out
with a policy about it in regards to mma
fighters
uh which is to me systematic
exploitation where they're getting 12 to
15
of the sports revenues uh instead of the
50 that other
sports are getting their athletes and
wwe
has a lot of parallels it's not a sport
in the same way
but it kind of has all the features of a
sport in terms of being talent driven
people risking their lives and
exploitation in the wwe's case so they
label everyone as independent
contractors uh meanwhile they don't get
health care
they don't get recovery time which is
crucial which is one reason why a lot of
these wrestlers get addicted to
painkillers and other drugs because they
have to go out there and perform all the
time and they're always afraid that if
they
say look i'm not gonna get out there
this week or
you know this month uh they'll lose
their spot because that's the way
vince works it's way uh the business
works
so this is all uh
flying in the face of them being
independent contractors particularly
when the wwe in particular controls your
life
more or less like they they tell you
where to be what to do
how to look how to act um you can't do
this you can't do that like they'll
control
tons of elements of your professional
life and even to some extent your
personal life and then they'll say
but no no like you're an independent
contractor yeah
yeah yeah and so i uh got angry and then
i went on a little uh tweet
storm and um i was prompted to the zac
uh by a professional wrestler who sent
me the original cameo story
uh like a professional wrestler who felt
exploited was like this [ __ ] is
ridiculous
so it wasn't just that andrew yang was
like you know
like got upset it was that some
wrestlers
were upset but could not actually vent
about it
because uh you know like vince
has absolute power and could and if you
are a wrestler who doesn't even work for
vince you can't say [ __ ] because you
might
eventually want to work for vince like
that they're
uh not quite a monopoly but um
but they function like it in in some
respects it's one reason why i'm excited
that there's genuine competition arising
in the form of
aew in particular because i feel like
that company has a real chance to
um introduce reform and that company has
a chance to
introduce reform in part because it's
talent friendly uh there are many
very senior executives that are current
wrestlers
uh and so it's a different animal than
the wwe
okay so i grew up in musical theater um
which is not cool but um and very
different than wrestling
however so to me you could look at them
as
athletes like professional athletes or
you look at them as actors
they're probably somewhere in between
there so if they're athletes
you pay them like athletes get paid and
they have a union and they get to
negotiate and they get paid based on
a chunk of revenue right like they do in
the mlb or nfl or any of these
any of these arenas or if they're actors
right actors have a union on broadway
they actually have
an actor's equity card where that you
can't get exploited they can't be
that sort of you need to give them
benefits you need to give them
xyz hours how would you use how should
it be
structured um and then why have we are
they
there's two questions one how should it
be structured and two why is it
are they in limbo is it just to me it's
like yes maybe vince is an
[ __ ] but i also kind of stuck in this
like we don't know what you are so we
can just do whatever we want with you
you know is that part of it too what do
you think on those two things
there was an online suggestion that they
should be unionized under the screen
actors guild because they are
essentially our
performers on screen and so sag would
take care of a lot of this stuff but
i think the professional sports analog
is closer in terms of the risk they're
taking physically
uh i mean for me the
big issue is what the nature of the
benefits they're getting so
if they get them because they're members
of sag
or their own union fantastic or if the
wwe were to say look
you're clearly employees i mean heck
like you know you we
control lots of elements in your waking
life so guess what you all get health
care you all get retirement benefits you
all get an off season you get all you
have this like
you know however we get there um yeah we
just need to get there
and one of the things i said which got
some news
or buzz was look if i'm not the
secretary of labor like i'll know the
secretary of labor like we can get this
done
uh and it's it actually falls under the
national
labor relations board but the national
labor relations board are
appointed by the administration so right
now you have a bunch of
uh trump appointees
who are putting any action under the rug
uh because vincent and trump are good
friends from way back
dana white and trump are also friendly
it's funny the parallels between
who owns ufc yeah wwe and ufc here
there's a lot of exploitation going on
uh and there are things we can do about
it as soon as
uh there's a different administration
it's clearly illegal to me
my question is like when this stuff
happens to other athletes there's
usually more uproar
and wrestling is super possible i'm
popular excuse me in its own
world right it's i mean it's massive
it's prime time yeah top some of the top
table rated
uh shows every week i think wwe last i
checked was a billion dollar business
uh you know i haven't looked at the
market yep lately but there doesn't seem
to be
the the same uproar you know i'm saying
is it because it's wrestling in that
you're either
you're the wrestling fan or you're not
there's very few casual wrestling fans i
think
um like why is there not as much uproar
or is it because a lot of these
fans of wwe maybe lean more right and so
they're less
they care less about it i grew up a
massive wrestling fan i feel like every
kid in my town did
so you know i don't think politics
really enters in myself it's like is
every 12-year-old leaning right
like i don't think that's fair but but i
agree with you i think wrestling has its
own domain
uh in the culture and it doesn't really
interact or intersect with
mainstream politics uh a lot of the time
ufc is similar
we're just no one gives a [ __ ] because
it's a fighter or wrestler and to me
that's so
dumb because these are people that are
humans
that dedicated years and years of their
life
honing a craft uh you know they're
risking
their bodies every time out there and
it's a billion dollar business so what
the hell are we waiting for
uh but i i agree with you that for
whatever reason
uh it doesn't get the attention it
deserves in the mainstream news
and i'm going to keep beating the drum
until that changes because i'm sick of
this like as a fan
uh it's upsetting seeing so many of your
childhood heroes
die early because these wrestlers are
abusing
themselves in order to keep their jobs
uh and then they
die of a heart attack at you know 45 or
you know like whatever the heck the age
is right um and they're physical
specimens too they shouldn't be
you know they should be taken care of
you know you're saying they're not
you know they don't they're these are
some of the most elite bodies in in
society you know
like they're they should be in great
health in some ways um
but they're dying because they're not
paid or not taken care of or
it's a it's a difficult lifestyle and
there are elements of it you can't do
much about
uh but they're elements you can do
something about and you should do that
so
i think in wrestling's case it's crystal
clear because
uh you know like they have a lot of
discretion over what
they can do um they're
i mean you could have an offseason for
wrestlers uh that's baked in
you know like they just get a month off
uh more
i mean heck professional athletes get
there's no off season
they just go all year yeah yeah
what if if you had enough you're the
rock you were going the whole time
you're just going if you are a high
level wrestler
you're still getting paid on like very
often an appearance basis
and so at that point you're making more
money than you've ever made
and you show up not just for tv tapings
but
if there were tours as there normally
are during house shows
so you might be performing
you know uh like 200 times like a
you know like in a given 18 month period
or something
like uh it it's like and so you can
imagine
and a lot of this involves travel to a
different place
so one of the complaints that wrestlers
have is that they don't get a break
uh and instead if you're a top draw
then the culture is like well you better
show up because if you don't show up
you're going to lose your spot and then
you're like oh snap i spent my entire
career
trying to get into this position so then
let's say you hurt yourself
you have to keep going yeah you hurt
yourself earlier that week
what are you going to do you're going to
pop some painkillers and get out there
uh and and so that that's what what
happens to a lot of these guys
for for those of you like me you're like
not didn't grow up a wrestling fan like
other stuff's fake
just watch a clip of wrestling like yes
it's fake in turn it's somewhat scripted
but if they're jumping from the top of a
rope they're still jumping from the top
of the rope right they're still slamming
their body on the ground they're still
picking up a full-grown man
um and slamming in the ground like you
know even if it's scripted or they're
not really punching each other they're
still taking a
beating right like you've it's it's a
gnarly sport
it's very very difficult on your body
you can liken it to stuntmen really
you know it's like like real life
stuntmen going out there and
uh performing and then packing up their
stuff and then driving to the next town
and doing it again
yeah um you ever see that movie
concussion with will smith
uh yeah that yeah there are parallels
there i mean that you know it's the nfl
he says will smith has a line in there
that i thought was fascinating he said
look it's not about whether or not
being a warrior is right or wrong um
because some people get really
you know when the football concussions
were happening people were like well we
shouldn't be
hitting each other that way he's like
that's not what it's about it's about
america needs to take care of their
warriors that's what he that's one of my
favorite lines in that movie
like we got to take care of they they
entertain us they um
you know we they've they're bred in our
system you know like we worship these
guys and gals
we need to take care of them i think
that's pretty logical and that's why if
you're listening this you're not a
wrestling fan
that's why you should care because the
principle of this that we care about
money more than people
um is pervasive about society and these
are massive examples
um america needs to take care of its
warriors on every level so that's
the veterans who return home that people
are risking their body for
our entertainment every given weekend
or every given week our nurses on the
front lines all of it yeah
um you uh so the final tweet on your
your thread was vince you'd better hope
your old friend donald wins because
change is in the air and
changes are long overdue where your
corrupt labor practices are concerned
it would give me great pleasure the
people know
so for yang gang out there that followed
him on the campaign
like i had the same motion you had like
[ __ ] yes yang like this is the
i wish you would take off the heads of
some of the maybe the
your democratic primary contenders at
times too but maybe you know there's
some political strategy there but i love
when you get angry
um and it's uh it's terrifying when it's
directed at me man but most of the time
it's pretty awesome to watch so
uh thank you for that sweet boss
[Laughter]
uh you get really you're really humble
about it too because you don't get that
angry um very often but when you do it's
it's a sight which i love
so i appreciate that um
gonna change gears um i want your
thoughts on this and i don't think you
have a lot of thoughts on them which is
why i think it'll be funny um
so it turns out one of the major
california wildfires
was started by a gender reveal um
so andrew i we were talking about a
little before and i want to dive in
i don't think you're familiar with
gender reveals or so
is it what i think of when jenna reveals
it's like
uh cake and you slice into it and then
like the
flavor of the cake tells you whether
you're having a boy or girl so someone
obviously knows and then you don't know
uh so that's what occurs to me but i i
did not know fire entered the equation
so they started these things and the
woman um
who popularized gender reveals um
not really i could do more research i
don't think people care of how that
happened but let's say the
woman credited for popularizing gender
reveals
said they've gone too far um this is
getting ridiculous but basically people
go nuts and they have these
um they're like canisters of
of smoke either pink or blue um and they
they have a friendly explosion um and
they've done anything from like pinatas
and baseball bats to soccer balls and
you kick it in turns of color
and some of them are cute but generally
no one gives a [ __ ]
um you know like no one and to me it
bothers me because
i don't know if your friend's having a
baby you already got to go to the baby
shower
and then you got to give another baby
gift um a gender reveal party which
people are having
and then posting on instagram and
youtube whatever it is is another way
to me just to i have to pay for another
gift um
let me ask you andrew have you ever you
didn't do a gender reveal for
for your boys no no we just knew uh as
soon as uh
it was medically possible for us to know
because
possible because like you know you're
i'm a practical sort
and uh was like well sooner we know
sooner we can
uh like yeah prepare yeah and
when when we found out that our
second was going to be a boy i was like
well i don't need to get much because i
think we
can just pass all the older ones stuff
down
um so to me what's going on with the
wildfires is
such a catastrophe and yeah
i you know i i tweeted that the weather
in la was 120 degrees over the weekend
it's a record
heat wave and then you're seeing these
epic wildfires all
over the state and the images
seem apocalyptic someone called it fire
porn where you can just look at
the the california wildfire
pictures and just uh have your jaw drop
and wonder that it's not a special
effect
uh and you know people ask about what we
can do
i mean this is a situation that to me
after the fire is out
or after the fire is raging
it's too late in the sense that it's
very difficult i mean you need to have
the right resources and everything
but ideally you'd be controlling the
fuel at a much
higher level where there are these
forests to become tinder boxes
as california is drying up uh it it
seems impossible but these wildfires are
just gonna get worse
yeah so a lot of l.a
people don't always realize this piece
is like a lot of la is
is desert right a lot and part around
san francisco in some places too
it's it's pretty dry um but mainly la
um in southern california to me
this is what seems to happen every year
we're like oh man wildfires are bad i
hope they're not bad this year and then
we kind of like there's someone in your
mind but then they come and they're
disastrous and we're shocked as if like
i feel like we didn't
we had a whole year to kind of prepare
for this or years and years we know
every year wildfires or wildfires are
terrible
um and you talked about a lot in the
campaign where you would
um quintuple the u.s forest service
forestry budget
yeah yeah which is and it's all federal
it's mainly a federal problem right
because it's federal
parks they cross state lines um
and then some of these places end up a
tinderbox and you know they're a
tinderbox like this is where they
normally
start uh that sort of thing what else i
mean do you remember some of the things
you talked about on the trail about what
you would do to fight
and prevent these in the future a lot of
it was preventative if i recall
now again after there's a wildfire
raging it's harder
to put it out so you'd want to invest
in managing the forests to a
higher level right now less than 10 of
the national forest is actually getting
managed for fire suppression so 90
is not less than 10 percent yes you you
would need to
invest massive resources to properly
manage
the tinder boxes that that are forming
these fires are easier to put out
earlier rather than later
where you know after they consume enough
fuel they become
uncontrollable so in addition to
investing the u.s forest service i i was
hypothesizing that
you could do more in terms of installing
heat sensors
uh in various acres of land and then
have some kind of rapid deployment unit
that
uh descended on the place as soon as you
saw that there was a fire breaking out
before it got too bad
now some people will be like wow that
sounds expensive
i mean do you know how much these
current wildfires are costing us in
terms of
uh not just property damage but loss of
life in many cases you're
looking at billions of dollars over time
so which would you rather spend money on
some freaking awesome fuel uh management
fire suppression
unit with heat sensors in your forests
or watching your communities get
consumed by wildfire
and this is a federal problem because
like you said a lot of these
lands are federal responsibility uh even
california right now
is being impacted by land that it
doesn't have
purview over so you know this is just
another example of our government being
asleep at the switch where
you look up and be like oh another year
another uh
another series of record-breaking fires
and it's like well someone want to do
something about that and
uh the the feds are like well we don't
really exist to
adapt we just take last year's budget
and then increase or decrease it by five
or ten percent and then we
everyone just chills out you know it
it's very very
frustrating if if i was in california
i'd be raging at the federal government
i'm raging at the federal government
anyway my yeah you're raising the
federal government without being
out there um my one of my buddies from
high school
um actually became one of the guys that
like
parachutes out of helicopters and fights
wildfires
um which is a a dangerous job but also
relatively intere i mean it's cool for
sure um but
and we're not a big fan of uh like
federal jobs guarantees or or
excessive government labor but this
seems like a place where
um there's a lot of particularly young
men that probably really interested in a
job like that especially if they're
unemployed or don't like their current
job or or that kind of thing because
that's a need that's not going anywhere
at this rate um that's where i think
you know where government resources be
wisely spent in my opinion
yes quintuple the us forest service
budget and higher the heck out of a
bunch of people that
would go in and manage the forest so
that we don't deal with
uh these fires uh breaking records every
year
you know and you talk about the
government and jobs i mean the reality
is we have millions and millions of
americans who are
unemployed right now and underemployed
so we should be investing in anything
that makes sense as a job creator and
this one's a no-brainer
yeah no-brainer
[Music]
all right everyone it's time to get
personal and a little bit
a little bit deep in detail but one of
the things i love to do is try and pick
up lessons from other countries where
they figured something out and we have
not figured it out
like the metric system something like
that you know what else they figured out
bidets they're environmentally
friendlier
they're more effective they're the more
efficient way to handle something
that we all do and now you can make that
happen
here without a new appliance it's just
an attachment i know this is like
technologically
awesome and environmentally friendly it
just seems a little
weird to americans but to the rest of
the world they're like
what are you guys doing you know there
are better ways
so if this speaks to you you can go to
hellotushi.com to get 10 percent off
their bidet attachment it's kind of
awesome
special offer for yang speaks go to
hellotushi.com
yang for 10 off i know
but i genuinely believe it's funny we
talked to the team about this they were
like
laughing and i was like i genuinely just
believe in bidets
you know i don't know what that says
about me but they're you know to me this
is just a better way it's a better
solution
it's more environmentally friendly it's
more efficient
uh it's just smarter so yeah
hellotushy.com
[Applause]
i want to change gears an interesting
story i saw because i and i
it reminded me of you but also it hit my
hometown so it touched them so i'm i
i'm a buffalo bills fan i lived in
buffalo for two years when i was little
but i grew up in
outside of hartford in connecticut and
so hartford had something
they're supposed to start schools after
labor day on tuesday and the
the whole public school system shut down
for an extra day
um because of something called
ransomware and someone basically hacked
their bus their school bus software
um and said if you don't ransomware um
is what they in this case was a virus
that said if you don't
pay us xyz in whether it's files or
money or crypto or whatever the hell
they they off you know whatever the
ransom is
the virus doesn't go away um and we're
gonna keep attacking your crap
um and we were joking about this for the
show andrew
is apparently this was like not a big
headline like i saw this because i
follow
some you know i check in on my my
hometown my people
um but this stuff apparently happens
all the time like ransomware is actually
kind of common and i
for some reason we just shrug like oh
don't worry the government got
hijacked today for a day we'll go back
to normal tomorrow
like no one's talking about this at all
and it happens pretty often like have
you seen this stuff like what are your
thoughts on ransomware
yeah it does happen more often than
you'd think like it's happened to dozens
of communities
and the tough reality is that it's much
easier to hack a lot of these systems
than it is to somehow secure them
particularly if you're a cash strapped
school district or whatnot like
the last thing you're worried about uh
is uh
now i'm in investing in being hacker
proof
unfortunately and then when someone
comes and holds your
uh feet over a fire saying hey do this
or do that
then oftentimes your move is going to be
like well
let's pay or let's cancel school or
let's and so these things are happening
around the country
and we're not making enough of it uh i
think we're not making
enough of it because uh we don't have a
solution in many of these communities
uh and i think it erodes public trust
even more
public confidence even more if you know
that your kid's school buses software
is hackable yeah though it
it almost certainly is uh
and this is one of the the symptoms of
of being behind the curve on a
government level
uh where at a minimum what you'd want to
do is you'd want to have like a really
concerted task force that's like look
anyone who does something like this to
hartford or a town
like we're going to investigate the heck
out of you and come get you wherever you
are
whether you know whether you're in the
country or not
but right now i i feel like these these
sorts of schemes
uh are getting swept under the rug
because people don't have um confidence
we can fix it
yeah when their mayor did say they
invested in new cyber security
technology and that that
shortened they basically stopped this
didn't have to pay ransom it only lasted
a day
um so it's better than i guess what it
could have been i wonder if
yeah sometimes they have to pay yeah
yeah
you can't expect every city to be
extremely tech savvy given
the type of country we have but i wonder
if the federal government could have a
list of approved vendors or approved
providers or have an an internal service
as well that we were
passionate about and hold those
organizations accountable
um to offer the states um
i don't know um to me you joked that we
were in a third world country because
like oh yeah
government attacked today don't worry
about it like that's where that's the
future we want to avoid um
if we can be in venezuela i don't know
uh just i felt bad for hartford i don't
think it's the mayor's fault
um yeah and that would be a tough thing
too being an elected official
and then being like you know what what
the heck like i was supposed to be
like you you know the tech expert here
in you know yeah
right or she gets blamed for it yeah
yeah so yeah like that that strikes me
as unfair
um but in our country today i would it
would be i
probably would fall on that person to
somehow shoulder the blame
of course yeah yeah that there i mean
there are things that we could do
along the lines of what you're that
you're describing but it requires like a
real overhaul
zach because a lot of these public
entities are using
systems from a long time ago
like you know you just need a massive
modernization push
here in the u.s because some of the more
modern systems
are more resistant and resilient oh man
all right on more positive news andrew
um a couple things one
um football is sunday
um you're a bigger nba fan so you're
probably having more fun but i am
ecstatic i think the bills are winning
the afc east this year
and josh allen's contending for mvp so
those are you listening who care don't
care it doesn't matter
you heard it here first josh allen is
going to have a fantastic year and the
bills are in the afc
it's our year baby i'm pumped and my
other prediction is that i think the
because of covid the teams with like
culture
and let's call it like um
consistent head coaching and consistent
ownership and management
will outperform so your ravens your
steelers your seahawks
the bills have been pretty good pascal
years your niners i think they're going
to outperform
thoughts on the season any predictions
any hot takes you want to make man what
are you
your nba takes people yell you see yell
at me on the trail because they were bad
maybe you'll redeem yourself with
football i don't know certainly my
football takes will be
uh almost uniformly poor
so uh so certainly you don't wanna
to give anyone any bad suggestions
though it does seem like the bill's
no one's betting on yourself i don't
think that's good um
yeah you know i mean the patriots if
they manage to
win post brady uh then everyone else
should just give up
[Laughter]
you know if the pats go to the super
bowl again
or contenders this year i'm out dude i
can't do it the they've
got so many players if that happens the
the bills the jets and the dolphins
should all
uh come together and uh um
just have some kind of ceremony where
they like submit to the patriots
i would be for that man because i think
you could because then you'd actually
say like you could put the best team
that the jets dolphins and bills could
put together and we'd probably still
lose
well that was actually one of the jokes
about where it was like
actually you should have all three teams
merge make it like a two-team division
uh and it would be like you consolidate
every other amc east eve you make like a
voltron super team um it's so painful
oh but your bills have a good shot um
you know i mean bills are good this year
um and hanging out with you too
for the bills because you know if you're
around someone uh who's rooting as hard
as you were
then you know like you naturally start
rooting for them too
well thanks man i uh i tend to make
everybody else's lives miserable when
the bills lose so
a lot of the staff would root for the
bills for their own self-interest
um to you know because that being a
better if the bills win people ask for
budget requests that's when they asked
for them
on the campaign trail um that's funny
about being great they're smart
way to manage way to manage up team
oh yeah teammates up great i'm like
putty in their hands um
most importantly andrew unagi
scooter giveaway yes
we did it we're doing we're giving away
three of them andrew
um and we're gonna do one on this
episode did you know that i don't know
if i told you that surprise you knew we
were giving away though
i i love these scooters and i love
giving them away because i know whoever
gets it's gonna be so
happy it's just gonna make their
like uh life better to have this thing
um
yeah you know it's like a 21st century
magic carpet
um yeah i i can't say enough about
how much fun these things are today's
winner the first unagi scooter
um is drumroll
first winner is caroline garrido
uh it's caroline underscore
g-a-r-r-i-d-o
all can follow her and congratulate her
if you want on instagram um caroline we
will reach out to you congratulations
you're gonna love this thing oh my gosh
i love this thing
i love it so much um and you know andrew
does if
i wanted to bore people i would just
post videos of you and me just riding
the scooter all day
because that happens every day i don't
know
um so here's the deal um
if you want a scooter we're going to be
announcing winners on our instagram so
that's at andrew yang and at zac
grauman on instagram the next
way to win will be announced shortly um
probably on our next monday episode
um regardless though we love unagi
scooters we love giving them away we
love giving [ __ ] away on the show
regardless andrew um
whether it's money unagi scooters
football advice what else do you give
away
mainly money i mean humanity forwards up
to eight million dollars and counting uh
plus so thank you to everyone who
supported
and continues to support our efforts uh
because there's just a lot of need a lot
of pain
and so being able to do something about
it is a real
gift and privilege so thank you um but
yeah we love giving stuff away
and and that includes fun electric
scooters
that's true um and i don't people prefer
money but
um we'll do money and we'll do scooters
and we'll do more too
um so our next guest is
he's such a badass i'm gonna butcher his
name um but uh
not out of um maybe it's out of being
the rinse but it has nothing to do with
how much i love him because i love this
guy
um how do i pronounce his name it's
kamel nanjiani
camille nanjiani he's a badass so cool
plus he got super ripped for a marvel
movie so he's like
at this point now he's super smart
super funny and super ripped and
he's been giving guidance to people on
how to manage their mental health and
uh the well-being during the the
pandemic
i'm a big fan of his too silicon valley
big sick
everything he does he elevates
and i can't wait to talk to him there's
a certain element
of um elevating your acting career from
like comedian
to action hero which the steps in
between
include a shirtless gq magazine cover
where you're ripped like um jim from the
office john krasinski did this
i'm trying to think of other examples um
but that i think that or the guy who
placed the
the um what's his name in who's darth
vader in star wars or not darth vader
um who's the bad guy in the new star
wars movies you know i'm timeout
adam driver kylo ren adam driver yes
same thing i don't know if he's been
completely shirtless but definitely more
jacked
i think it's a rite of patches passage
here's a thought andrew
between now and the next office you run
for
we get you jacked evelyn would like this
we get you jacked like you were in like
high school college
and we do uh we announce as a shirtless
cover of gq
or you can pick the magazine i i feel
like that would uh probably
not help my seriousness factor no
you know but it but it wouldn't but it
would help
my prospects being cast in a marvel
movie so
you know there'd be like a
cost benefit and you just had like a
yang gang tattoo
on the left peck like something badass
but like not like a joke yanking like uh
i don't know like blood or awesomeness
i don't know um there's some fans
listening to this that i think are
loving this visual that i think it's
hilarious uh sorry
sorry you're not as excited about it as
i am but i think
i'm cracking up uh this is one way to
launch a new
office run okay i'm done man i'm done
tuning guys camille right after this
[Music]
break
[Music]
yang speaks listeners you know what time
it is it is time to plug
our featured sponsor expressvpn and
they're our feature sponsor we don't
just choose that lightly
we created this partnership with
expressvpn because we believe in the
product
i'm using it right now i was watching
last night i was watching rick and morty
i think from australia
um through my expressvpn on netflix
because
um i don't have hulu i use netflix
because they have rick and morty
in whatever country it was and i got new
shows on netflix because of expressvpn
but it also protects your data protects
your location it protects your privacy
it's simple oh my god it's so freaking
easy to download this
this thing um because i'm bad at this
stuff you literally just download it
and then click a button to turn on so um
this thing is rated number one vpn on
the market by wired and cnet and the
verge
it's not just us saying this this is
pretty much unanimous that these guys
are the best so here's the deal
protect your online privacy today with
expressvpn we're gonna give you three
months of expressvpn
protection for free expressvpn.com
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com for three
months free
with the one-year package visit
expressvpn.com to learn more about this
awesome deal and protect yourselves
people geez let's be smart about this
stuff
[Applause]
i am thrilled to welcome to yang speaks
uh what no what has he not done
actor comedian screen writer
uh visionary philosophy and comps
eye graduate of the
kamehameha welcome to yang speaks thank
you for doing this oh
well thank you for having me thank you
well that and now i feel like you're
almost you're the closest thing our
society has to a superhero right now
because we all know you're super ripped
[Laughter]
you had to go through the hollywood
training crucible
where the the task masters at disney
assigned you
a dietician and trainers and uh
the whole nine yards for the regimen uh
and you know it cracked me and my wife
up because we're like
imagine your husband just coming home
and being like hey for my job i now have
to become
essentially a real life superhero yeah
well
first of all i want to say you know they
did get me all those
uh people they gave me the
infrastructure to do it disney but they
put no pressure on me they were like
if you want to do this you can but
seriously you don't have to and i was
like
oh i'm gonna do it the most possible
i really emily was like you know they
don't want you to do this you're doing
this because you want to do it i'm like
yeah i've always wanted to like i've
always wanted to do this and i just
haven't had like the time
or the determination to really like see
see it through
so it was it was kind of awesome to do
it was
also a real nightmare and a real pain
and it continues to be
oh so that's one of the questions i had
is that so you show up you're ripped
you get footage uh of you for this movie
the eternals and then i'm thinking to
myself does he have to stay ripped until
this thing raps
then what the heck is that yeah well
you know for me i i i have
tried to stay in shape uh since then in
the same way you kind of
my goal was until the movie comes out
when you go and do the interviews i
didn't want to
look like radically different on the red
carpet than i do in the movie
uh so that was my goal and now you know
the release date for the movie got
delayed so i have to
i have to keep at it a little bit longer
but it's interesting you brought up
my wife because she he does
she's still a little surprised by it
every now and then she like
like hug me and she'd just be like you
just feel so different and
and i feel the most different when i'm
in bed trying to like
turn like sleep on my side i could feel
it's like trying to steer a ship and
like i'm not
used to doing that movement yet
i thought you're gonna say you have less
padding than you used to it's like
you turn on your side and you're like oh
it's more muscle there there used to be
some cushion
it really is less padding it's
interesting the way that your body
the body feels different
um i was gonna say something but i feel
like that's
that's a little bit uh inappropriate so
i'll leave it
oh you can get as inappropriate as you
want man it's a podcast one of the
things i
um i had in mind when i was running for
president was if it's a podcast it
doesn't matter
if it's a podcast it's like no one will
ever see this and it's just gonna
disappear into the internet whereas
you know if it was like cable news
appearance and all of a sudden it was
very very serious stuff
uh so that the stuff that and you might
have gone into this in a setting that i
have not seen
but the thing that fascinates me about
you is your origin story because i have
no
[ __ ] clue how a guy would come from
pakistan here for college study computer
science and philosophy at grinnell which
is someplace i know i campaigned there
and and then some somehow wind up
like a tv star movie star um when you
have really educated parents i have
educated parents too
and my parents would not have had any
thing to do with me
if i just disappeared for a while it was
like i'm going to
do do comedy uh you know they didn't
like
it very much when i said politics which
is a pretty serious thing
i think so i yeah if i was running for
president my parents would have a
tough reaction yeah my mind were not
thrilled either but
the thing that is this mystery to me is
so i i can see your
background through college that stuff
makes sense to me and i don't know if
you remember this but you and i met
briefly
at the global entrepreneurship summit in
silicon valley
uh we were both in line to get pictures
with uh president obama
uh i don't know if you remember this you
you and the cast of silicon valley did
the skit ahead of time and then we were
just like chilling in line together do
you remember that
i do remember that and it took us over
two years to get that picture because
they had to vet
everyone that was a long ass line and i
gotta say camille not to be
like not to sound cocky whatever but
like i had a picture with him from like
you know like a couple months earlier so
i was like why am i doing this again
i've already seen this movie i know how
it ends
yeah it ends with uh you know me shaking
uh obama's hand and him
talking about how awesome i am
[Laughter]
he was very that was the most i've
talked to him he was very charming
funny and i was actually supposed to
have dinner with him
at one point um i think it was towards
the end of last year
and then i had to be out of the country
and i couldn't do it and i was very very
disappointed
uh but yeah that's that's the only time
i've met him
well so to me there's like this massive
fog of mystery
between camille the recent college
graduate and then
by the time i saw you in the world saw
you you were a
tv star uh in silicon valley was when i
think most of the world met you
uh and so i know you you've done the
clubs you've done the entire circuit
um like tell us about that time because
that time
just strikes me as such a ringer
like the fact that you flung yourself
into that ringer after grinnell
man i'll tell you starting stand-up
comedy uh
is an absolute ringer it really really
is it's
it's it's difficult and i started
honestly i started
in uh i started like august
2001 is when i started doing stand-up
comedy
so if you remember your history then
it's
9 11 happens that year and i continue
doing stand-up comedy
looking like me sounding like me with my
name
getting up on stage in front of drunk
people trying to tell jokes
so i always have this thing where like
you know sometimes you will troll me on
twitter and then they'll be like are you
feeling hurt and i'm like
man whatever it takes to hurt my
feelings
you don't got it i promise i've been to
i've been through some of the worst
situations so
basically how it works is i i graduated
college in computer science and
philosophy one of those
is practical to get you a job and the
other one is
not as practical the issue was you know
i
i found philosophy very interesting and
i was very engaged and i felt like i was
good at it like
i could make pursuance of arguments i
was good at writing papers i really
enjoyed it
computer science i always felt like i
missed one class somewhere and just like
never caught up i was like
not good at it managed to get a job in
computer science but
never really felt engaged never felt
like it was for me
and and i'd sort of at that point really
fall in love with
with stand-up comedy just watching
stand-up comedy so i was like
i have to try this thing like it would
hurt too much to not try it
and how it works is you know i moved to
chicago for a job but i also knew that
chicago's where like a lot of comedy
legends had come from you know steve
carell steven colbert bill murray like
all these
big people tina fey so i moved there
and you basically look through the
newspaper see where the
open mics are and you just go and put
your name on the list and then you get
up on stage and you get five minutes in
front of in front of
people you don't know and that's kind of
how you get started and you know the
first few years i
my visa was tied to my work so i
couldn't actually make money doing
stand-up so all i could do
was open mics and that's kind of what
you do you just
from 2001 to 2007
i just did open mics over and over
in front of drunk people in chicago
and then i got you know i got pretty
lucky
over and over and over and over it was
right place right
time over and over you know uh so so so
so the reason that
i'm here a lot of it is due to
is due to luck and i feel extremely
grateful i always say
of all the parallel universes this is
the only one
where i'm here talking to you this is
the simulation
where you become a movie star this is it
man
in every other one i i i got nothing
going on
so so i feel i feel very very grateful
and i feel very very
very fortunate it was one of those you
know where you
you're doing comedy so i moved to new
york in 2007 with my wife emily and we
were to like sort of pursue comedy and i
just ended up
having a good set in front of somebody
who then later got me a job and then
that job led to another job led to
another job led to another job so it was
all these
small steps leading to uh
leading to the career i have now um
but but at each point there was like um
serendipity you know i
just like the right person saw me at
just the right time or or things like
that and then
all sort of fingers crossed you know
i know this can go away at any second
well there's a big gulf there because
you're on a visa and you have a job
where you were working with computers
and then you're showing up to open mics
and don't make a dime and just
you know get pelted with occasional
abuse and how do you get better at your
crap
so then when do you actually switch from
making a living
from sitting in front of a computer
screen to making a living off of comedy
and then how does the visa work
like when does the visa actually start
becoming something you can apply for for
being a creative
so this is how it works works for me
what you have to do
is get heckled by a beautiful american
woman at a show
fall in love with her have her fall in
love with you marry her
and you get a green card so that's how
it works
right place right time man i'm telling
you again
um so that's how it worked for me you
know if i if i
getting getting a creative visa and i
know friends who've gotten it is
very very tricky because you basically
have to prove that nobody else
who's american can do this job and what
we do is so
amorphous and vague and and hard to
articulate anyway
but but how it worked for us was so we
met in 2006 i was still on my
i was in my second h-1b visa which
i i think that there's still a hole that
h-1b visas so so i
really really relate with that issue i
was on my second and final h-1b
visa met emily we fell in love as my
visa was running out
we were like we should we should get
married and it did not feel like
a practical decision it was a decision
made out of
out of love we knew already at that
point we've been through some
camille loves his wife
and she says she loves me
[Music]
you heard it here first and yang speaks
um
so we basically got married i applied
for a green card got the green card you
do the whole
interview you know where there's a woman
who's like we had a woman who was trying
to like
trick us and make sure that that our
love was real
what color is her toothbrush
[Laughter]
it's that kind of stuff it really is
what helped us is
you know we had um so we did
our own we just basically stood in line
at city hall and got married
and then when we went to meet my parents
you know when her and i went to meet my
parents we were already married we'd
been married for two weeks
and even though emily is not the person
that they had imagined in their heads
i mean i give them all the credit in the
world they fully accepted her and they
threw a traditional pakistani wedding
and they had a pakistani videographer
there and this guy
made a dvd of our wedding that is the
cheesiest
[ __ ] thing you've ever seen it starts
with
a picture of the guy actually editing
on his thing so when you put when i put
in my wedding dvd the first thing
is this guy editing and the song do you
remember that song of
i will be your hero baby of course
who does not know that song it's enrique
iglesias
i will take away your pain yeah it's a
good song
but i don't know if you wanted playing
on a loop over your wet
wedding video over and over and over so
we took that with us you know we just
had enough like
evidence that obviously we weren't lying
and then as soon as we got
married so now the video you're like
check this out and then the person's
like well
make this up because she's like okay i
guess he got a green card
that allowed me to quit my equip my job
we decided to just like move to new york
with savings and no money which was a
huge mistake
and she's a therapist so she basically
was like
i will get a job and support you you can
follow your dream and
she just believed in me man i don't know
i don't know why i think even her
friends and family were like he's
he's a great guy but what are you doing
he's a great guy but what are you doing
that's like the definitely
the butt after that
[Music]
what's wild is how much you still have
to mail stuff i just mailed stuff
today and when you need to mail things
there are times when you're like am i
going to go to the post office
am i out of stamps do i have envelopes
and all of that stuff
and one way to make it so that you
always have what you need
is stamps.com we used it on the campaign
we had this freaking post office in the
campaign office it was actually quite
fun
it made me feel very accomplished
looking at that but now that we're
in this circumstance stamps.com can
actually make it so that all the stuff
you need
from the post office is right off your
computer
and you don't need to go you'll save
time and money and you'll feel very
modern
and current right now listeners to yang
speaks
get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page
and type in yang that's stamps.com enter
yang
and you will get some stuff including
free postage
and a free digital scale no long term
commitment
why not really you know it's 20 20.
why not just let stamps.com actually
save you that trip stamps.com also
offers ups services with discounts up to
62
and no residential surcharges that's
right stamps.com works for ups too
[Applause]
well i i have a uh you know like at
least
a sense that i understand that era from
the big sick
as i'm sure a lot of people are watching
listening to this if you haven't seen
the big sec
you need to see it it's a brilliant and
touching and poignant movie
but it's somewhat autobiographical
in terms of uh your relationship with
emily
uh and some of that era like you're in
clubs performing like you tell some of
the jokes that i imagine you might have
told in real life
um yeah that kind of belief that that is
profound
where someone sees something in you that
maybe you're not even
sure about all of the time because
you know when you're putting yourself
out there as a creative
it's hard to believe in even yourself
all the time
yeah especially because you know you
just know the numbers you know i mean
you don't know specifically the numbers
but you know that what you're going for
is
so rare and so hard to achieve and so
many things have to line up exactly
perfectly and
you know emily still says that she never
doubted that
that i would be i don't know what what
she was thinking what would happen but
she never doubted that i would have some
level of success
um in this industry you know it's the
same
we sort of have that for each other i
think like
i believe in her more than sometimes she
believes in
herself and vice versa um
so i am you know honestly if it wasn't
for her
i would definitely definitely not be
here right now so she
she basically supported me for a year
and a half while i
did open mics in new york i sort of had
to start over there and then
i sort of got a job like opening for a
comedy
for a comedy tour then i got a job
writing for a tv show and then that show
gave me a job acting so it was all like
these tiny little steps but it all
happened because emily
took a job and supported me for a year
emily seems like a creative powerhouse
in our own right and anyone who wants to
listen to the two of you you have a
podcast staying in uh that is
kind of quarantine themed as people
might be able to tell it's about
trying to stay stable and mentally
healthy
during a time when we're spending a lot
of time indoors
with with ourselves or our significant
others
and it's honest it's funny uh you know
like the the two of you seem like you
enhance each other creatively is the
sense one gets from the outside
yeah we we certainly enhance each other
creatively
and i like to think personally as well i
feel like
we both think that we got the better end
of the deal
i think she thinks that i definitely
think that
so it's definitely a little bit greater
than the sum of
some of our parts you know it's um even
though we obviously have
our issues everyone does but i feel like
in
quarantine specifically because you know
you mentioned the big sick so you might
know emily's in a high risk group for
this virus right so we have to lock down
before most people lock down and we're
still very very strict about it
um it's just too scary we really we
haven't seen anybody we only leave the
house at night and go for a walk when
there aren't people around
and stuff like that so in this time
just really spending time with only each
other
um it has strengthened our relationship
and it has made
our uh communication a lot better i feel
like you know it's it's
sometimes it can be easy to take your
partner for granted and not
ask them like how are you feeling how's
your day going how are you doing this
week that just that basic kind of stuff
you know it can be easy to go on
autopilot with that and i think
quarantine
has shown us that those conversations
just being like
how are you feeling is very very it's
just
it's just essential and it's also me
asking her
how she's feeling gives me more
intentionality in the way
i approach my life during this too
because uh
you know all we all literally all we
have is each other right now
well before we move on to another topic
we need to expand h1b visas in the
united states
it really makes no sense our current
system and i have friends who've gone
through versions of it
uh and the fact is these companies have
to jump through
a million hoops to say look only this
person can do this job i can't find an
american to do this job
but in real life the choice is between
them hiring those folks and having them
live and work in the united states or
them hiring them
in another country and to me
which would you prefer if you were us
them hiring hundreds of people
and having them here in the us where
they end up creating value
and uh being massive value generators or
that company opening an office in
pakistan or
india or eastern europe or wherever it
is like to me that's a very easy call
and you let that you let them hire who
they want here in the united states and
then you get that value natively
every knowledge worker ends up
supporting
multiple workers in other aspects of the
economy which is pretty obvious if you
think about it but if you you get hired
by this firm and you're working as a
programmer or whatnot you're going to
end up pumping a lot of money
for the takeout restaurant for the
landlord the dry cleaner the cleaning
service the dog walker like you name it
it all ends up just circulating back
through our economy
as opposed to someone else's economy oh
yeah
as you said it's just value-add the
other thing is
there's a sense you know they talk about
immigration reform there's this sense
that
the gates are wide open that anybody can
come to america
nothing could be further from the truth
as a kid in pakistan
with my family just trying to get a
visit visa to america to come visit
uh my my sister's brother it's almost
impossible it's
so hard just to get a visit visa
especially from a place like pakistan
getting it when an h-1b visa as you said
companies have to jump through
a lot of hoops so so there's this idea
that anybody can just move in and it's
easy it is not easy it's a
very difficult process and there's a lot
of vetting that happens
just the thought that you might have had
to leave the
the states if you had not fallen in love
with emily et cetera et cetera i'm sure
is like making everyone think it's like
wow
i can't imagine uh an american cultural
landscape without
camille honestly like over the last
really you can well that's
well that's very flattering i don't
think it's true but
i feel you know obviously this is my
country this
is my home and the idea that a big
let's face it a big chunk of this
country does not see me as american and
does not accept me as american
even though i know it's not the problem
is not with me the problem is with them
it's still a little heartbreaking to me
and it's still it still gets to me
you know uh the fact that what is it 44
of the country probably wouldn't see me
as as belonging here
i feel like you might be an exception my
friend where if they've seen you in
something then all of a sudden
uh you become familiar to them in a way
that
that that might hopefully uh engender
you know some positivity i feel like
you'd get that if you went to a lot of
places
and when you were performing your comedy
i feel like you might know this country
in a way that a lot of people don't
because comedians
head to small towns and medium-sized
cities and
work like a a club where like you said
like you know a few dozen drunk people
show off
you're there and you're there with a
bunch of other comics and you end up
staying
overnight in places that a lot of
americans will never see and never visit
did you have that experience
as a comedian or were you more
exclusively in chicago and new york
um i certainly had that experience not
as much i couldn't do it in chicago
because i couldn't make money so i would
go sometimes do their shows just to do
them but certainly in new york i have
done
tours of tiny tiny towns and you know i
grew up in a really big city i grew up
in karachi which is like 20 million
people i've
i lived in chicago i lived and lived in
new york
so i was always very like metropolitan
going to these small towns was really
very eye-opening because i'll be honest
you know before i went to them
i was a little bit i thought oh i i
i don't see the appeal like if i lived
there i would move out but then going
there you do a show in a tiny town i did
this show
think of this specific one i i did a
show in a tiny town in ohio
then afterwards everybody went to a bar
and all the people from the show went to
the bar
and i was kind of hanging out and
talking to these people who'd sort of
grown up there
and some of them had been like best
friends with each other since the second
grade you know
um and i thought that that was really
beautiful and
even though a lot of these people may
not agree with me politically now
i really i realized that
as trite as this sounds we all truly
have a lot more in common than we don't
i know sometimes it's that gets obscured
by
by um but just the conversation and
and sort of the screaming at each other
but uh i i
it made me feel ultimately optimistic
about about where we're headed
in this grand experiment genuinely think
comedians
uh could be the great unifying force
of our society in part because of
of those experiences that so many of you
have had that's a lot of
pressure to put on a bunch of drugs and
drug addicts dude
it's just in well one place that feels
very very uplifting
and i'd urge you to try and get there
though i guess it'd be far afield for
for you uh and you know that you're you
know you're probably not gonna you know
break isolation
um but dave chappelle has uh
has a cornfield near his house and he's
been doing live comedy shows there with
uh comedians who just
come and go essentially i think that
their nickname for it was chappelle
summer camp
so yeah it actually takes some of the
ingredients you're describing where
it's a very small town but people are
discovering
it's essentially like a field of dreams
of comedy the whole thing blows your
mind like you go there and because it's
a cornfield everyone's spread out
it's very socially distanced you're just
like what am i seeing i'm seeing like
some of the best comedians uh
in the world in this corn field uh
and it felt quintessentially american in
part because of the backdrop
it's like just fields of corn in the
summer there's a gazebo
anyway so um but but the comedians i i
talk to because they interact with
people the same way you do it's like
look we all
have a lot in common we all want the
same things uh and there are these
political discussions that are trying to
pit us against each other
in a way that i don't think would apply
if we were just sitting across a kitchen
table from each other or if we were in
the same bar at the same night
like then you would just end up bonding
over your common humanity
instead of you know typing some nasty
comment
in twitter or facebook or
or what have you um so i'm
i'm serious that i feel like uh
comedians are having a different
conversation with americans
uh than politicians for sure like a
better conversation in many respects
i think that's right i think that's
right um
what you said about you know i one of my
best friends in the world is indian
people always like a pakistani
indian and it's like yeah those lines
don't exist
when you're like sitting next to someone
or eating with them you know i always
find like if you look at the big thing
there's a lot of
eating scenes that happen whenever
people uh
whenever walls come down and people
connect and i really feel like you know
if
if the world could if i could
bring some of these people in and and
feed them pakistani food i don't think
they could think of that place in the
way that they think of it right now
because
because our food's too good yes
well said camille's effort will be like
pakistani restaurants across the country
letting people know that this place is
too delicious
to dislike that's right i mean that is
what we are we're too delicious to
dislike
that should be on our flag that that i
mean that's a pretty good tag line
uh comedians and chefs bringing the
world together i don't i don't mind it
uh so when you talk about the politics
of this moment so you've got a green
card
um are you a citizen now or are you
still trafficking and i am in prison now
oh so you have the freaking full rights
and privileges you took the test
was the test as hard as they say no
the test was pretty easy um in fact
why i don't know how much i could say
because i don't because i read something
where they were like oh we can start
revoking citizenships and all this stuff
you're in for good don't worry man you
can spill the beans nothing's gonna
happen
it's irreversible i i went in
and i sat with this guy and i was really
nervous and he was an asian
he's an asian guy very nice and uh right
from the beginning he was like
he asked me a couple questions and then
he saw i was nervous and he was like
don't be nervous you're gonna pass don't
worry about this and i just thought it
was
really really sweet like he didn't have
to do that he he didn't have to put me
at
ease you know he didn't have to make me
feel better
the person who interviewed us for the
green card certainly didn't do that she
was trying to get us she was trying to
get us to contradict
ourselves and and you know she was like
she was certainly like
aggressive uh but this guy was was super
nice so that that test wasn't
it was not that hard no so yeah i'm here
for good can't get rid of me
yeah look at this full rights and
privileges so
so and you know you're paying oodles and
taxes which will make some people very
happy yeah
california it's a big percentage
okay this episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by freshly
okay this is a i'm gonna call this a
command for everybody listening
stop eating like crap and that might be
projecting because i've been eating like
crap
except when i eat my freshly meals
because they're pretty good and they're
super
healthy um because it's simple you can
avoid the grocery store which avoids
covid
and you get these fully prepared dinners
delivered fresh not frozen
right to your freaking door so you're
gonna get
golden oven fried chicken not the oil
fried chicken but also
creamy risotto but then you've got beef
brisket that falls apart and it's
beautiful and awesome and
healthy and then there's 30 other health
conscious options to choose from
at freshly so join one and a half
million satisfied customers of freshly
and skip the shopping prepping cooking
and
clean up and stop eating like crap so
freshly
is offering our yang speak listeners
forty dollars off
their first two orders at freshly.com
yang that's freshly f-r-e-s-h-l-y
dot com yang
check it out it is worth it your body
will thank you your wallet will probably
thank you
freshly.com
uh so you and i connected in part
because there was
uh an asian american political event
we're trying to rally folks in the
community um
do you have a different perspective on
what's going on politically as a result
of the fact that you had to
essentially fight to stay in this
country you become a citizen
uh and then now you are in my mind one
of the most
prominent pakistani american figures
which and i'm i can relate to aspects of
this because
you know there aren't that many like
asian american um
uh presidential candidates no not not
that many
let me see how many i can think of
yeah there's andrew yang in this um so
uh i feel like you became a citizen just
as our country started to really
um turn against each other or feel like
it's getting torn apart
um and i take it that you're
with so you know about me like i've
endorsed joe and kamala like uh you know
i'm trying to get
folks to just vote vote vote because i i
feel like the more people that vote
uh the better off we're going to be uh
but i feel like you have a different
perspective because you're like a kind
of a recently minted american
you're just like you had to fight to get
it and then here we are at this
political moment where it it feels like
there's a ton at stake uh in november
yeah you know i always feel like
obviously uh
i relate to immigration issues very
intimately
and this the demonization of immigrants
you remember when they were talking
about the caravan from mexico and stuff
i it never first of all i find it
obviously
moral and immoral and unethical
but on top of that it's also extremely
illogical because
you know you were born here we
had to like fight to come here we chose
america as our home
we gave up our lives you know we put
everything on the line to choose
to choose like better lives for
ourselves and our families i mean
what's more american than that right the
pursuit of
life what is it life liberty happiness
whatever it is i don't remember from the
citizenship
from the test test was too long ago that
was a long time ago
but to me that should be something
that's commended
i mean these people are patriotic they
chose america they weren't just born
here so
so i find that i it just never makes
sense to me that people are able to
demonize immigrants so easily
and yeah obviously this election is very
very important you know my parents
moved here after i did my parents have
been here now
maybe uh like 12 years or so
um and they moved from karachi and they
they landed here and they loved america
you know they were like oh my god things
are like
much easier here they felt really
accepted they just my mom was
like seeing her that happy and that
comfortable it just
brought so much joy to me and then in
the last few years
it's been very difficult for her you
know her relationship to america has
changed and the way she looks
the way she sees america has changed
now when i talk to her
all she does is really talk about
politics and how scared she is
and she says they don't want us here i'm
like no
mom this is like there's a certain
percentage of people
this is not how it is things can turn
very quickly and she was like she said
something that really broke my heart
she's like we already
we already left pakistan where where do
we go from here
where will we go when we have to leave
here that's so heartbreaking
you know she's been here for 12 years
and she's happy for the first 10 years
and then the last two years she's like
wait a minute like i'm not sure if this
place actually
uh wants people like me yeah it's been
it's been really really really
devastating you know and i and i sort of
tell her this is something that
you know this is the the difficult
balance right like how do you stay
engaged and and up on the news
and still keep your wits about you like
how do you keep your mental health in
check
while the world is seems to be falling
apart
so so i tell her i'm like you know you
you know how you're going to vote you
know how your friends are going to vote
don't watch the news all day every day i
don't think our brains are designed
to really take that much stimulus over
and over and over this is how i feel
about twitter even though
i am on it more than i should be
if you look at your replies i bet you if
you look at europe lies even if they're
positive it's really overwhelming
i don't think we're supposed to get that
much
information that much communication that
much feedback from that many people
at in like such a short period of period
of time
you don't think that was happening in
the state of nature where you say
something in the campfire and then all
of a sudden like
hundreds of people step out and start
telling you
with their opinions only people are
caught
tweeting you to dunk on you no that did
not happen this is all completely new
so that's what i tell her i'm like mom
there's too much news right now
too much is going on i have to i have to
take breaks very very consistently
and so that's that's what i try and tell
her but yeah i mean there's a lot
wrapped up in this election for all of
us and
specifically for me because i just keep
thinking of my mom you know sometimes i
wish
i lived in a different state so my vote
could actually count more
well you can make a huge difference uh
trying to move votes
in swing districts around the country
and i agree with you about there being
an optimal amount of news and social
media to consume in a given day
uh i've been so i i'm on cnn
uh and cnn has 24 hours of news uh but i
grew up in a time when there was
approximately 30 minutes of news
it was like just and here's your nightly
news and we'll do it again like the
local version
and and whatnot and i'm convinced that
there's an optimal
amount of news that significantly less
than 24 hours uh because
the fact is if i have hours of bandwidth
of content to fill then i'll talk about
something
you know and and i'll try and make it
interesting um
and i'll gin up emotional responses to
whatever the heck i'm talking about
uh and that that's a and social media is
that
compounded and you'll write that right
so i'm
i'm very much on twitter um and it was
part of my presidential campaign so it
was very
uh it was very
high utility and it continues to be high
utility because i feel like it's
my responsibility and i feel i think you
you and emily
clearly feel similarly where it's my
responsibility to try and put some
positive
sentiments or ideas uh out there because
people
kind of turn to me for a sense of uplift
and you know i'm very touched by that
and i want to
be that uh and you know and and so
it's it's like a function of
uh who i am now and part of my
professional role
um but it occasionally someone in my
twitter feed will be like oh i'm trying
to get off twitter i'm like go
you know yeah leave exactly
i i after this election i'm really gonna
like take a step back from twitter i
i've certainly done that as you see i'm
more active now than i was a couple
months ago and that was by design you
know i was like
as we get close to the election i'll see
if if i can use my platform for any good
maybe i'm just fooling myself but
at least at least you know the attempt
is there i can like look myself and say
well i
i did something you know no matter no
matter what happens
um but i think you're right it is high
value i got on twitter because
it helped my touring tremendously you
know you
when you would go to like before
before people know your name if you're
going to a small town
um usually you do like radio shows and
stuff and you're sort of getting a weird
smattering of people who've heard you
who've heard you on that radio show but
but if it's twitter that's a very
targeted thing that's a self-selected
audience right those are the people who
want to hear from you
so i started on it because um because
touring
i didn't have to do like 6 a.m radio
shows with like
douche bags anymore you know um and
so that was that was very helpful and
what you said about people looking to
you for
for uplift and positivity i think that
that's
that's very very important and that's an
essential service i was
emily and i have talked about this you
know in a time like this
um as people who like make stuff
i think there are two ways you can go
right you can like fight against
something
or you can fight for something and i
think
i think both are very valid i think
fighting against stuff
is is very valid i think that there are
beautiful pieces of art that have come
from cynicism
and anger um and negativity like
beautiful pieces of art and i find them
essential
i think our role is to fight for
something that's just
i think how our personalities are that's
how our brains work that's that's how we
see the world both emily and i
are by nature very optimistic people and
we're generally very
pretty positive people um and so so
that's what we sort of decided we try
and do stuff
that that fights for the positive rather
than fighting
against the negative which i do think is
is still
a uh it's a it's a very very valid
battle
we have this show on apple tv plus
called little america
that's a show that we created that's an
anthology show so every every episode is
completely different and then the
anthologies show based on
true stories of immigrants to america
and
and and that's the kind of stuff we want
to do
you know it just sort of these are like
very small stories some are
some are sad some are happy some are
funny they're all
some are weird and quirky some are like
exciting and thrilling
uh one's like a sports movie you know so
so that's that's what we sort of decided
we wanted to do is
we we want to put stuff out that conveys
our point of view
in a way that hopefully makes people
feel
a little less lonely and a little more
optimistic
well that's what i hoped my presidential
campaign
would be camille is that before
something present a vision that people
can get excited about
because one of the frustrations i have
is that in politics a lot of people will
just point out the problem and then
being like we should really think about
what to do about that if they just move
on it's like well i'm kind of
sure that we should actually put
something on the table
and so when i started my campaign and
you know i was for universal basic
income still am
and saying hey we should give everyone a
thousand dollars a month like people
were
uh treating it like haha like that's
impossible
that that you know can't happen and then
now fast forward
not that long uh afterwards 55
of americans are on board and something
like 75 of americans are for cash relief
uh and a lot of it's that you present
this positive vision you say look
like you know i'm with you and that i'm
naturally
uh optimistic and constructive it was
funny too is that when i was running
people
presented me as like the doomer
candidate because i was talking about
how ai's gonna take the jobs and you
know the the
self-driving trucks are gonna lead the
truck i mean
you gotta have that conversation too
yeah
yeah but i know so it's funny is that
people saw me as doom and gloom on one
hand but then i had this
uh this relatively positive manner
and i thought like a vision where it's
like look like we don't have to just
wait for
the truckers to riot like we can try and
like build a runway for everyone so that
we can start
like planning for a future that i think
is like right around the corner
and then now the pandemic ended up
speeding it up yeah
i think you're exactly right i think
your campaign did so much work in moving
the conversation in a positive direction
bringing up
bringing up things and ways of looking
at problems that
i thought was very very constructive you
know the effect you had on the campaign
the effect your campaign had on the
conversation is still
profound and being felt and i think you
talking about
ai taking jobs and stuff it's so weird
to me that people don't want to hear
that stuff or talk about it where if you
think about it for 30 seconds
it's inevitable that that's where we're
headed and that that's something that we
need to be ready for
and deal with you know especially
because we're dealing with
we're in this situation where massive
tech companies control our lives in ways
that are
so complete and thorough
we've given up so much just to have
um just just for convenience that it's
it's really shocking how quickly it
how quickly it happened and and you know
obviously mark zuckerberg and facebook
is
is in the news all the time i think
that's a great example
of of a massive massive
tech forest that's affected the way
that's affected the world and i believe
to be a profoundly
profoundly negative way and so i think
these conversations are
are essential we can't ignore them
anymore i have friends in silicon valley
who could not watch silicon valley or
show on hbo because they said it just
hit too close to hope they were like
it's too real
you know the first time it it's really
interesting because our show we started
filming
in 2011 i think maybe 2000
no wait wait what maybe 2013 i forget
but when we when i was doing the pilot
you know it was my judge it was hbo i
told my friends if i'm doing this pilot
they're like what was it what's it about
and i said it's called silicon valley
and they were like oh is it set in the
90s
i'm like no there's crazy [ __ ] going on
in silicon valley right now it's weird
to think
back then we didn't know i mean some
people did but we didn't know who elon
musk was we didn't know who peter thiel
was like people had not heard these
names
now these are household names um
in the six years that we ran or the
seven years that we ran
the way that people look at silicon
valley has changed
so quickly and for me it was a real
wake-up call because i think it was
season two or three
we would sort of do these trips right we
would go to silicon valley and we would
show the episode and we'd sort of like
tour companies and get to see what they
were working on and they were very
excited to have us because
because you know we're we're doing a
show about
about about what they do i was stunned
at what little thought was going into
the moral and ethical ramifications of
the technology that they were working on
um i remember i won't name the company
but they were
showing us this new product that's now
on the market that many people have and
they were like you do this can do this
it could do this and so we brought up a
privacy
concern and it wasn't they didn't
have they were shocked that they were
asked
this question they didn't even have like
a fake
corporate answer ready to go they were
stunned
and a little upset and disappointed that
we would even think of that i feel like
there's a sense in the tech world and
i'm sure
you know this much better than i do the
technology
is completely amoral uh it's a tool you
make it and how it's used well it's not
up to us well
i don't think that's right i think first
of all there's no way that
laws can keep up with technology and i
do think it's the responsibility of
people developing this technology
to consider uh the negative the possible
negative uses for it you know um
i can i mean the deep fake stuff all
that stuff i
i don't think you can just like keep
developing and close your eyes and ears
to the fact that these
things can be can be really misused
they're being misused every day in part
because they serve the almighty
marketplace
and we know right now the marketplace
just wants to monetize us and our
attention
um whether or not that's good for
democracy our mental health
humanity free will our ability to come
together and solve problems our ability
to settle on
back to the truth uh you know we're
we're all now
just subject to this this surveillance
capitalism machine
that sells and resells us to the tune of
200 billion
a year yeah that's what you always hear
where you're like if the app is free
you're the product and so
right now i'm trying to help people uh
wake up to what's going on with our data
and our privacy rights there's actually
a prop
in california in november prop 24 that
i'm super excited about
that it's going to create a dedicated
data protection agency in the state of
california to look out for
california data and privacy rights which
right now a lot of companies are frankly
just totally abusing and just being like
whatever like
there's no enforcement of course so if
prop 24 passes in november then all of a
sudden
uh the state has to create an
enforcement agency and mechanism
and then you're going to see corporate
behavior change because until there's
until there's actually someone looking
after and then showing up and saying hey
like that there's a problem here
uh so so believe it or not this stuff is
cutting edge right now this stuff's
literally on the ballot in like a matter
of weeks
good i mean that's the tricky thing you
know if you see like these hearings when
like zuckerberg or any of these folks go
the questions they're being asked it's
it's scary they're not inspiring
it's not inspiring stuff about the most
basic
tech stuff like it's just it's it's
really upsetting that um
honestly i mean this prop 24 vote yes on
prop 24 that's good i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna use to twitter to get that
word out
because i do think that that is sort of
the big existential crisis that we're
heading towards right now
is is uh is big tech i think
i think it's a formidable foe i feel
like for
all the great stuff that the internet
has done
i think it's it's it's i mean you know
it's it's it's fractured the
conversation
so much to the point where it's not even
a conversation i remember when i was a
computer science major
i would go to my professor's office and
he was this guy he was like a
philosopher
and a computer scientist and he was one
of the
you know original guys who was involved
with the internet and stuff and he had
this quote on his desk from a group of
early people who were sort of trying to
talk about
uh technology and the benefits is going
to provide humanity and he said
something like
the rise of the internet is the promise
of the return of voice
um and i found that so inspiring i was
like that's true
the promise of the internet is i can
talk to someone
in bulgaria you know i can like have a
real conversation with them you really
can connect with people
who have different experiences from you
different perspectives from you see the
world entirely differently and you can
have a conversation with them in reality
what's happened is you just find the
people who exactly agree with you
and then you just talk amongst
yourselves and then you yell at the
other people who disagree with you
so it's really gone in a completely
different direction
i think these original sort of tech
thinkers had thought
had thought it would um and i i don't
know how i don't know
i don't know where we go i feel like the
internet is like this
serpent that we made that's now
swallowing us whole
uh one of my goals uh is to get the
serpent under control camille and like
i may actually have that job uh before
too long
if if things head in a particular
direction i hope they head in a
particular direction you know it's funny
i was just using to myself the fact that
uh i feel like you're one of the most
prominent voices in this direction
because of silicon valley which is sort
of ironic because obviously
it you know it was a television show and
yet i feel like everyone identifies you
so closely
with this set of issues in part because
you know we just watched you on hbo uh
for years on end i know and i'm just
saying stuff that they wrote for me i
really shouldn't be the guy don't look
to me for any insight into it but
but you know we we the the writers and
the creators were very
very i mean they know knew all these
ceos right so we
it's all real like you know the fact
that it's like art imitating life or
whatnot plus the fact that you you're
genuinely like a computer science crowd
who worked in the field for years
uh so i don't know if that helped them
cast you or they're like oh this guy is
really convincing
well no because that was really bad at
computer science i never got it but i
was just
it's funny to go from sitting behind a
row of computers
being the worst guy to then being on set
sitting behind a row of computers and
being the best guy
like i was the only one out of the cast
that like understood a little bit what
the code was
uh so that was a weird experience it
didn't really you know
it didn't really help me too too much
knowing the tech side of
it um really what you know my my
approach to it was just was the
character itself
like that type of guy was was really my
way in
well you did a phenomenal job uh on
that show i can't wait to see you on the
big screen
uh with the eternals you're a literal
hero to so many people
and a force for progress and reason and
humanity i mean your family's story is
incredible it's such an american story
and we have to let people know that
you're american
your mom's american i'm american and
that uh america is us
it doesn't look like a particular um
set of images that maybe one but one
political party is putting out there
being like
hey let's just try and like conflate
this with america you know
america's us it's you it's it's uh you
and yours
exactly america looks like the world
because the world is in america i
remember the day
i got my citizenship you're in the room
and you
you sort of do the pledge and everything
and then a video played and the video
was a music video
that they had made for this proud to be
an american and it was
like cowboys on horses and like little
white girls on swings and
and then obama comes on was it the
actual song i'm proud to be
an american because ugly wow they really
use that when you become a citizen it's
officially the citizenship song of the
united states
i'll tell you man it sounds cheesy but i
had tears running down my face
in my head i was like i'm proud to be an
american where at least i know i'm free
but then obama comes on and he gives you
the speech this really moving
speech about welcome to the country
you're here now you're one of us
and i just felt so full of hope and
optimism
and i don't know what's happening with
people who become citizens now i can't
imagine that there's a
there's a there's a video that plays
that makes anybody feel
i have a feeling they replace the obama
part of a feeling that they
they like changed that part they
probably kept the first part no
oh i'm sure they kept the first part
there may be some maga hats added to it
well i i tweeted during the rnc that i
really like that song
uh because i do really do like that song
like they they play it i'm proud to be
it i was like i really like this song
and then all these books it's tough all
these folks were like oh
like i used to love it oh they ruined it
for me and i was like oh they haven't
ruined it for me i still just love this
song
um yeah yeah so you're relating that
experience i mean um uh
like i'm proud you're an american i know
a lot of us are
camal and hopefully we can keep that
that
uh energy and belief strong
so that your mom feels right at home
here uh you know
really as soon as this elections are but
even before then
i hope so thank you that's very kind of
you to say thank you
thank you such a pleasure commandant
johnny let's keep an eye out he's got a
podcast with emily
and he has the show little america it's
on uh apple plus
so you can check out some inspiring
stories of uh immigrants doing great
things around the country
and that show is free right now so you
don't need to have a
subscription to apple tv plus just go on
your apple tv search for little america
and you can watch all the episodes for
free
little america's free on apple plus
that's great
speaks people love free so yeah check it
out
yeah i know you have the time to watch
it right now thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you